let's bring in Michael Vick who joins us
Mike thanks for joining us you remember
your first car yeah what was it
Nissan stanza okay my freshman year in
college yeah how did that play with the
ladies with a Nissan stanza I mean
listen we really got four wheels and
somebody else - four wheels and then you
win it pick you up and take you on a
date that's all about what did you get
when you went to the NFL
my first vehicle I purchased when I went
to the NFL was a Lincoln Navigator and
that's when they had first came out and
funny thing is when I first got it like
the first three months I died I just
couldn't believe it was my truck you
know born from a Nissan standard to a
Lincoln Navigator he's talking about a
car that I paid you know $1,100 for as
opposed to a car that was around 60,000
you know uh it was a bit overwhelming
but uh yeah it was it was a amazing
purchase I will tell you that what was
it like first time you went out with the
Falcons owner Arthur Blank it was very
intimidating I was uh you know 22 years
old but he loosened up a move you know
he talked way more than I did and I was
very nervous I'm not willing to say the
wrong things and wanted to say the right
thing is it did you think you had to
pick up the check what's that did you
think you had to pick up the dinner
check do I do I think he'll answer no do
you think did you think that you had to
pick up the dinner check that night when
you went out with mr. blank yeah only
because as at that point I was being
employed by the latest ography he's the
owner and I really thought that because
he was paying my bills and because he
was employed that
you know I need to become revealed so I
tried to cover them first and he's like
that you know that's not Lerner did just
kind of don't don't you know don't rush
it you know let me if somebody wants to
because in a nice gesture so you think
just let it happen action I wanted to
have you on for a couple of reasons
first of all first of all we talked
about these quarterbacks who like Lamar
Jackson or Tyler Murray where they're
they're really good runners but then
eventually you're gonna have to be good
from the pocket how difficult was that
where you know you can run you know you
can make plays but you might be better
for your longevity and the team by
staying in the pocket and then trying to
throw how tough was that transition for
you
you know what the transition wasn't
tough for me because I felt like in
college we use my running abilities am i
passing abilities um almost to even par
standard when I got to the NFL it was
more pass heavy and you know not as much
running if you if he was running he was
improvising and you know when I think
back on my career all I wanted to do
early was become a better passer because
I've seen it advance the ball down the
field a little more as I ran the ball
more you know it was more painful I was
sore I was you know so at night not
feeling good and then I just came to the
conclusion that you know if I became a
better passer I would protect myself I
will feel a lot better and we would
advance the ball down the field a lot
faster and it looks better you know from
a quarterback perspective so I you know
it was very early then when I realized
that I needed to change as a player and
it started in like 2002 2003 that season
and then Dan Reeves and I had a
conversation and I just told him coach
call the player for me like you called
them you know for your guys in the past
Elway Chris Chandler and he did it and I
became a much better passer who was your
idol growing up playing quarterback my
idol growing I was figure
was the San Francisco 49ers fan Steve
Young just happened a bit a lefty doc
coincidence and uh you know I felt like
you know if I wanted my game to look
like anybody that wanted to look like
his especially after that run in
Minnesota
that he here early in his career that I
don't think anyone would ever forget
now you're right-handed you didn't you
didn't become left-handed just so you
could be like Steve Young did you know
well when my dad put the football in my
hand and when I was eight years old I
was starting with my left hand and he
kept trying to make me throw up my right
hand he thought I was throwing it with
the wrong hand
maybe he just didn't know so he kept
putting in my left dad it just feels
better throwing it on this side and you
know so you know that was my evolution
as the left-handed QB and I'm glad that
he I didn't change because this is no
way you can go from being left-handed to
right-handers and vice versa throwing a
football or in any sport but also that
you're very gifted but why is it
different coming off a left handers hand
you know receivers talk about getting a
ball from a left-hander as opposed to
somebody throws right-handed yes the
difference it's a different spin and
especially when it's coming with some
velocity to get both the ball gets up on
you really really quick from what I've
been told but the great receivers it
only took him about a day or two to get
adjusted I think the guys who adjusted
to my border fastest was rowdy white and
DeSean Jackson and Jeremy Maclin did a
good job with it so you said that Lamar
Jackson's is spitting image of you yeah
I think so if you look at Lamar's game
and just as explosiveness was in the
pocket the things you do within the
pocket and you go back and watch some of
my film abusers box the games all four
quarters you see similarities in so many
different areas and you know Lamar's an
exceptional talent I like the way to use
his talent in Baltimore and I think it's
gonna take them a long way as far as his
career what I do realize is that you
know he gets down when you're needs to
sometimes you take the necessary shots
but that's
gentleman and that's something you can't
take away from the right now I don't
know if you saw this but Kirk Cousins
apologized publicly to Adam feeling
after Thielen said that you know Kirk
Cousins missed some throws there they
become one-dimensional I how surprising
is that like the why is Kirk Cousins
apologizing publicly to Adam Thielen
it's not like he tried to overthrow him
or miss him so I'm I'm surprised at them
you know I think that's a class that
moves from Kirk Cousins first of all I
respect them for that and what Curt
understands is that look we have the
ball in our hands every place and it's
our responsibility to get the job to get
the ball to the receivers you know
orchestrate the offense make sure that
everything flows and maybe he missed
them a couple of times and just feel bad
about it I felt bad when I used to miss
those never apologized publicly I would
do it in private but I think that's the
classic move it shows leadership it
shows that he's he's taking the reins of
everything that he's doing it and taking
it seriously and you know want to
fortify his position moving forward so I
yeah I think it's a great leadership
move and hopefully they'll get it back
on track
you can catch Michael Vick on Fox NFL
kickoff that Sundays at 11:00 a.m. 8:00
a.m. Pacific on Fox Cam Newton situation
I've said that if you know cam is not
able to be the like that
two-headed monster being able to run and
throw and he's just gonna be a pocket
passer then I wonder what his NFL future
is you know if cams not able to run the
way he once did are not willing to run
the way he once did what do you think
that does for his effectiveness with
Carolina I think it takes away from what
cam brings as far as his attributes
we've known camper being this big strong
powerful run a Superman type of player
and that and that's where he's shown
over the years I would hate to see cam
not being cam and uh you know hopefully
can't be come to the realization
realistically if I can't be myself then
what's the best option for myself in his
team and uh you know I think cams a
smart man I think he'll figure it out
fortunately for him he at the time
because of the great quarterback play
right now where he can go out and uh you
take this time and and work his way back
into the lineup if it comes down to it
but he can get healthy most importantly
I want to know how good a basketball
player you were and how good a football
player Allen Iverson was if you guys
switch sports who had it who had a
better chance of playing professionally
yeah I think he was a much better
basketball player than me I was about a
B minus B plus player you not getting
attacked Iraq and I had to jump when I
got high Alaa was a he was a amazing
football player and he could devastate
it in so many ways very elusive I just
don't think he would have had he would
have got to shine it to play in the NFL
I think probably his heaviest he
probably could have gotten some 185 190
that's not enough at the quarterback
position so respectively we both chose
the right professions and we knew what
directors want to go in and what over
the best for us yeah but Iverson played
now he beat Kyle Emery wouldn't he yeah
he would be without one thing I will say
that he was dangerous like I said I mean
I don't know Kyle is still a little
bigger kyle is about 200 and looked like
seven or eight pounds give or take
I just don't think Allen would have got
that size honestly you're you're a 39
and are you the you're not the fastest
guy in the NFL or you wouldn't be the
fastest guy in the NFL but who would be
faster than you right now
right now I think Lamar will be back
today
I think counterpart will be fast
delete problem I mean I'm not probably
and uh DeSean Jackson yeah you shot
Jackson for sure I mean he's still 32 is
that's not considered old in the NFL and
it's a couple speed demons are still out
there too but uh you know when I when I
think about you know some of the guys
who is running it moving around you know
the way they do it
you know I probably could still do it
you know it would have to take a year
training to get back in shape just to be
able to look somewhere like I used to
could you run a four or five after
breakfast yeah if you catch me after the
first meal of the day I can put some
more yakking I can lay down a full a
half four five if you catch me out to
lunch then who knows
but being different these days if you
ran backwards and Brady ran forwards
would you beat him in at 40 no I
wouldn't disrespect that's not a no by
the way you're just not you're not
you're choosing not to answer it we take
it back to the combine because I mean
who wouldn't know when that guy was
running our 40-yard dash that he would
never have to use that forty in in a
career game and he would turn out to be
one of the greatest of all time so bad
man yeah running back was out of edom
own that day yeah but Mike I don't
understand why the 40 is that important
anymore because how often do you run a
40-yard dash if I'm a lineman I don't
care about you running a 40 as a running
back I want to know how quickly you get
to the hole like I think 10 10 yards is
more important than 40 yards to me yeah
I think the 40-yard dash is specifically
important for defensive backs receivers
safety guys who really have to pursue to
the ball as a quarterback of running
back you know we don't have to burst as
much for running back is to and through
the hole
how fast can you get to the hole the
next night with blazing speed but for
defenders they have to break on the ball
how to run with a receiver or DB having
to run it would achieve lenders receiver
having the betta DB that's when the
40-yard comes into play on that vertical
stretch we had Brett Favre on he turns
50 next week and I said at age 50 can
you throw at 60 and he said oh
absolutely
oh yeah I know for sure bring five they
thought probably just feel towards 60
yards we still like still look like he's
not in the best shape but I mean he
still looks like he he don't look back
he don't look like he's overweight or
anything like that branch they look good
and similar all these commercials
throwing the football yeah but you see
who's rushing the passer on those
commercials Michael yeah you know we
know Brett was the magician at the
position hey great to talk to you as
always have fun this season and tell the
folks at Fox NFL kickoff we settle oh
that's Michael Vick Fox Sports NFL
analyst first pick of the Falcons back
in that oh one draft first quarterback
to rush for a thousand yards in a season
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]